hello everybody welcome back to let's
play cry of fear okay I took a little
breather because my hands were still
shaking after that first one but I'm
ready to go because I am so tough oh
look at me I'll bring it on you know I
got nothing on me with that lion who's
out there it's hard to tell like I don't
know how easy it's gonna be to tell
which doors actually open if there's
like nothing showing all right what we
got here where am I all right
hello mom my angee unforgettable on
phone I can't see I'm not gonna make you
listen to me sick
okay um I saw something a message up
there I can't read it okay um how about
up here oh here we go excelsior
haha alright um jack-o'-lantern
nope nope nothing how about here ah
gotcha
thank you for leaving that clue um
windy uh let's see
painting that light flickering uh got a
computer and if you use your name or
password
uh uh what munch uh I don't know I guess
I have to find oh um the two notes I got
maybe we try that
um goes on X so C or ha
bingo whoa that seven two one six okay
seven two one six that's the combo for
the UM via a padlock
hey who open this door
I thought there was a load time in
between I don't know what happened to
that oh I am creeped 7 21 6 okay let's
see um uh where am I going
um what is with these knockers hey hey
um seven two one six okay I guess I just
go back to be fine
somewhere out there don't have like a
battery on this one or something I'd
hate to run out at a bad time
no thunder no lightning ha nope just
trust REM eggs huh you Garhwal punch
door won't budge okay there we go dot
dot dot
7:21 six okay help me I'm on my way
buddy seven two one bingo so bro
Oh what's yours automated I am okay you
probably don't wish you were because
this doesn't look good and I do wield
the option said to do wield or love to
do will be bad boys I don't know and can
save my life
go punch no aah
back off buddy what what the look to the
right no I don't wanna
and I'm starting to regret playing this
in the middle of the night with no
lights on to be able to record my
thoughts and experiences as like
Resident Evil okay
saving progress hey who's out there
announced to to perform a melee attack
no Mouse two switches weapons or
switches style there we go
small amount damage go use it to push
attack enemies when surrounded what what
F can I kick
uh-uh
dude that was me oh I'm the monster is
that blood on the floor yes I would you
know be careful bro ham uh-huh
okay he's kind of how the [ __ ] did it
even get here hey this is a family game
oh yeah get him get him get him get him
get him
Oh get some you ready to go you're so
twitchy aah aah no no aah
Becca Oh GoPro aah what's up bro who was
he I killed him oh man oh please ba-dum
it yeah no signal go out go back to life
you came and get out you're underground
aah it's gone ok this is normal
perfectly normal
all this is perfectly normal picked up a
syringe why Oh
restores health too much can be
dangerous ok oh boy Oh No something at
the bottom a ladder
oh man ah it's a guy get ready to get
some uh-huh nope nope nope
row row row row slow
ah gotcha oh so man they do not have
water like this in half-life 1 so that's
pretty good hi I see ya Twiggy Twiggy
Twitter's in correct um up get some nice
ha that the skirts of blood shooting
everywhere ah so twitchy wrong with you
bro okay got you oh I wish I could do
wheel but there's got to be a way to do
wield a knife and phone because uh
sometimes the top of the ladder okay
we're good oh good we're good huh we're
good RL I'll figure out how to do a
wheel look to the right stop telling me
to look to the right I'll figure out how
to do weald after I cut next but for now
I'm gonna keep going you got ah well
that's a fan an idiot
DoubleTap directional keys or hold all
oh that's handy
okay save my life ah yeah yeah ah God
throw stroke hahaha I didn't even need
this before but I'm not using that give
me that
aw fu buddy what's wrong with your
eyeballs ah ha ha get the - just one ha
ha
whoa I'm the best - shucks keV oh oh did
that hurt a bully Oh baby
ha ha ha ha ha ha you're fast fast oh
man I knew something was eventually
gonna jump out of the corner complainer
from me ha ha fast
not fast enough oh my sprint meter needs
to recharge all right
ok splishy-splashy oh well that opened
the gate ok
yeah you better back off I'm ready for
you oh yeah ah help me please help
they're coming I'm inside the apartments
hurry well that's gonna have to wait
because I gotta cut it here but thank
you guys so much for watching and I hope
you're enjoying it because I'm gonna
keep playing so thanks again and I will
see you in the next part
bye bye